l'attitude des états unis remise en
cause sur le dossier afghan après leur
départ en août et la prise de pouvoir
par les talibans la situation dans le
pays est très délicate pour moscou
l'avion au sol chinoise doit s'imposer
comme un partenaire et aliments ce sont
les propos de vladimir poutine eut point
sur cette déclaration avec notre
correspondant à moscou en pointe claire
bladimir poutine à l'occasion d'un
sommet de l'organisation de coopération
de shanghai a dressé un bilan peu
reluisant de l'état actuel de
l'afghanistan en cause d'après le
président russe la façon dont les forces
de l'otan se sont retirés du pays aux
ados comme un soudeur
après le départ précipité des américains
pour ne pas dire la fuite avec leurs
alliés de l'otan ils ont tout laissé
derrière eux une boîte de pandore
ouverte plein de problèmes liés au
terrorisme au trafic de drogue au crime
organisé est malheureusement à
l'extrémisme religieux
et cet état de fait a bien entendu des
conséquences concrètes sur la situation
sécuritaire du pays mais aussi sur les
pays limitrophes toute cette région
d'asie centrale ainsi le président russe
attache beaucoup d'importance au rôle
joué par les plateformes régionales de
dialogue c'est le cas avec
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective cette alliance politico
militaire qui a organisé la semaine
dernière des manoeuvres militaires
conjointes au kirghizstan leur but
dissuader toute tentative d'agression de
la part de groupes islamistes qui
seraient tenté de déborder depuis
l'afghanistan tout proche et puis il ya
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai et de lors de ce sommet le
président russe a appelé à mener une
politique commune et concertée sur le
dossier afghan
aujourd'hui notre organisation est
confronté à la tâche urgente de mener
une politique commune et concertée
compte tenu des risques sérieux lié à
l'aggravation de la situation en
afghanistan
après le retrait précipité pour ne pas
dire la fuite des forces américaines et
de leurs alliés de l'otan de ce pays
car nous comprenons bien tout ce qui se
passe en afghanistan se projette
directement sur les intérêts
sécuritaires des états membres de l'osce
et s
d'autant plus qu'un certain nombre de
nos pays ont une frontière commune avec
l'afghanistan
en conséquence vladimir poutine a appelé
à la reprise des travaux du groupe de
contact entre l'organisation de
coopération de shanghai et l'afghanistan
ils souhaitent également la tenue d'une
réunion entre les dirigeants de cette
organisation l'organisation de
coopération de shanghai et les
dirigeants de l'organisation du traité
de sécurité collective afin de discuter
des questions pratiques liées à la
coopération avec l'afghanistan